either gets me about you guys is you
were flying from your home country at
the time in Dubai to come to my events
in London we're leaving Dubai we're
leaving our jobs and we're going back to
England to be full-time in properties
how many of you all four properties of
people how many of them are hmos three
once they're all completed and
refinanced and rented with your rent to
rent how much cash flow will you expect
to make from those five to six thousand
a month if you want to be financially
free from property then you need to look
at the proper strategies and educate
yourself when there's a crash people get
scared and they don't buy and actually
that's the time you should buy I knew
what we knew now then we would have
bought another property
before you hear that amazing story of
how they flipped a house in Dubai made
over a hundred thousand pound profit it
all started at the one pound property
course I have to say with sadness and
heaviness in my heart I'm gonna be
running the very very last ever one
pound property millionaire intensive
this month in July 2023 I've been
running these one pound courses for ages
and it's changed thousands of people's
lives so if you want to come and join me
this month in July I'm going to be in
Birmingham Manchester and London for the
final time ever running the one pound
property millionaire intensive Lincoln
bio enjoy the interview thank you so
much for coming to my house thank you
you too have been a massive inspiration
in the property Community you've
recently become property Millionaires
and the thing that gets me about you
guys is you were flying from your home
country at the time in Dubai to come to
my events in London I mean that type of
doing whatever it takes is what I think
has got you to where you are today so
congrats on your success thank you thank
you where did that motivation come from
to get on a plane and fly from Dubai to
come to a property course like most
people are like when's the next one
happening in the pool and they won't
even travel to Manchester where's that
motivation come from I think we've
always been really motivated people
firstly in our careers but we've always
wanted to get into property we bought
our first property 10 years ago and when
there was a bit of that property crash I
remember and we were living in West
London which was a really expensive area
and but we'd both been saving really
wanting to get into property
um so we were just looking at one bed
Flats in the area and we we managed to
find one and it was actually a
repossession wasn't it and it was on for
290 and we managed to get it for 275.
and this was 10 years ago yeah wow and
we did like a light refurb on that
property before literally what three
four months later we left the country
and we did our good around the world
sort of tripping and we relocated the
Dubai because I got a job there and then
we just left it to run for for 10 years
just letting the agents run the tenants
remember think and now it's worth like
400 yeah about 4
almost half a million so made great
money there was that just like literally
you bought it with your savings just as
a long-term investor the standard kind
of save up for as much as you can get
the deposit down yeah yeah and then
while you're in Dubai you did a flip
made like a hundred and yeah 100 over
120 000 pounds from buying and just
selling yeah we bought it we really
wanted to invest we researched the area
so much we lived in Dubai we really
wanted to buy we were getting itchy feet
again to buy on property yeah it was an
interesting situation we've been there
for five years and most people over
there they detract you from buying
property they said don't do it's too
risky it's too risky it's too risky that
was the narrative a lot of people said
and then one we've been there five years
and we got to the point where we were
kind of at the end of our tenancy
agreement and we're like let's just have
a look and we looked at the market was
very it was pretty low and I did a
little bit of due diligence and people I
knew that out they've been there all
their life they were like the prices
you're getting now you'll never ever get
again so we're like okay we're kind of
sold on buying in Dubai and I think from
then when we looked at the property in
the area that we were reported yeah it
was basically an amazing location but
it's where the properties were all quite
run down if you can get run down
properties into buyers the area it's a
great area close to the marina close to
the beach
um close to shakeside road but all those
properties are quite run down and to
rent them they're not in very good
condition a lot of them we thought why
don't we buy one and do it up so we
bought it to live in and as expats you
have to put down minimum 25 as you would
a buy to let even though we were having
it as our own home so we scraped
together everything and even took out a
secondary loan to put the deposit down
we got four-year loan and then paid it
off in a year and a half so we and we
did up the house piecemeal like room by
room as we were getting savings and
unfortunately well unfortunately covered
happened and as a result of that we sort
of accelerated the plan because we
didn't travel we didn't go on holidays
didn't we do much so in that kind of
year we really paid down the loans we
could Why didn't it take you so many
years why did it take you you bought
your first one 10 years ago what was
with the like the nine year gap before
doing your Dubai because as soon as we
bought the London one we traveled the
world and then moved to Dubai so we're
in a different country My Lifestyle for
the first year or two yeah and we had
never
ever being abroad and investing back
home did you have to pay tax on the
money no I was totally tax-free yeah is
that because you were because we lived
out there so long we lived out there
nearly eight years but had we have gone
out there for a year or two and then
flown back would have been so you made
120 was it yeah 120 Grand tax-free
buying a house for how much we bought it
for 1.2 million Euros so that's about
yeah about about 214 and sold it for 1.9
which is about 400. wow that's
impressive is that something that you
did you think that would be a good
strategy to keep doing injuries that at
the time I I thought why is no one else
buying properties because there was so
much on the market so cheap and I was
one it was no one like capitalizing on
this moment it's that typical thing
though when there's a crash people get
scared actually that's the time you
should buy if we had more money we would
definitely have probably done one or two
at that time but within six months of
buying property prices started to go but
now in the UK like people are scared so
and again you've capitalized off that
you've seen that interest rates are
going up it's becoming a buyer's market
in England isn't it and you've bought
how many houses in the last few months
four uh yeah we've bought four in the
year we've been back how are you finding
the money to keep buying all these
houses like where is it coming from uh
well we've used the money that we've
made from the Dubai house we also did a
huge renovation on our London flat and
then refinanced it so we pulled yeah
that's 10 years worth of Equity Building
up yeah yes we had quite a lot of equity
because we did that thing that most
people seem to do and just try and pay
down the mortgage as quickly as we can
because we thought you know what you're
told by your parents is to pay off your
mortgage so when we were living in Dubai
we were sending money back to the UK to
pay down our mortgage
now then we would have bought another
property yeah and we just kept oh we
wish we'd bought more property but so
you kind of would like dabble in a bit
in property also working in in very time
intensive jobs what were your jobs at
the time in Dubai what were you doing I
was in the fitness industry
so I was originally a trainer in England
and I moved out there as a trainer and
then got into some more management
managerial roles so I was doing that the
whole time and you're working in yeah I
was working in travel retail so I worked
in their fashion accessory
um area I was a global head of travel
retail for a international Luxury
company so yeah traveling all around the
world and working with really great
Brands so it was an amazing job but um
yeah when we had our daughter you kind
of your priorities change and it was
almost that with the cult covered thing
where everyone sort of reevaluated what
they're doing in their life and we were
going actually
we then stumbled across well Kirsty
stumbled across yourself after we did
the whole Rich Dad Poor Dad did that
sort of series of audio books yeah we
listened to Rich Dad Poor Dad and that
was just like a light bulb moment
because we thought we've got if we sell
up and move back to England we've got
this pot of money
we were like in houses in your hometown
in Taunton they're about at the time
about 180 Grand each for like a two
three bed Terrace we were like if we
could buy two of those on a buy to let
mortgage and we'd be making
like net profit maybe 300 400 pounds
each a month so 800 pound net profit a
month we're like we can't live on that
we're like how do people do this how do
people buy property and then become
financially free because even with a big
pot of money that we had of with for
them selling the Dubai house that would
just give us 800 pound a month we were
like we can't live on that and we're not
looking at this right and we listened to
Rich Dad Poor Dad and the light bulb
moment that your home is not your asset
and looking at property and finances in
a different way and then yeah I came
across you on YouTube and loved your
videos I was like James you have to
watch this so after our first holiday
after Kobe in 2021 you extended your
stay in England yeah and then you did
usually back to Dubai stage I stayed for
the summer and
and just so our daughter could spend
time with family and yeah I saw your one
pound crash course like my flight was
the next week and yours was the week
later and I was like oh what do I do and
I rang you and I just delayed my flight
and my mum looked after our daughter
Everly and I just went down for the day
and I was totally overwhelmed you know
because it was it was a big event
and unbeknownst to me I was sat next to
Evans and we got chatting and I'd never
yet seen his Financial Freedom Challenge
on your YouTube when you watch the
YouTube channel and you see people on
Windows on a Wednesday and documents and
then you see everybody in real life it's
like oh yeah everyone's around because
it's a small
the property world what was it about the
that one pound course then because
obviously you've been in property a long
time you bought probably 10 years ago
and you've done your flip in Dubai what
was it about that day that made you so
like excited and and got the blood
flowing I think it's the Financial
Freedom intensive that's what I signed
up for um because I was just like how
can we become financially free from
property I want to do this full time I
loved my job but it was just too much
with having a daughter I want to be
around for her more how can we be
full-time in property and make this work
and become financially free and I you
know really felt like you had the
answers and so I signed up for the
course and that was the Financial
Freedom intensive and the deal selling
masterclass and that one it was in the
November but obviously I was in Dubai so
I flew back to Dubai just for that
course on my own
um
I just did it in secret because I
thought they would think I was mad
so what did you think James I was all
for it because this is a plan we kind of
concocted in the preview in the summer
and we said this is what we want to do
because the last thing we wanted to do
was move back to the UK and start our
careers again yeah we wanted that to
have that open playing field of like
we're just going to completely transform
Our Lives essentially and do this full
time so I was all for you yeah you took
time off to look after everleigh while I
flew back I even had to it was that time
of covid so I had to do like a covered
test to fly back and my family were
actually out there in Dubai at the time
when I did that so I had to go for a
covert test and they're like why are you
going for a covert test and I couldn't
say I was flying home tomorrow that's
crazy so you just you just thought that
they just wouldn't understand it and
they try and talk you out of it yeah but
I feel like oh it's scam it's too much
money like they just didn't understand
at all so I was just like I just want to
keep this to myself and so and then when
I was back doing the course in England I
rang you didn't I from from England and
I was like I signed up for the academy
and I really want you to do it too can
you start out too and you were like what
yeah because you know when you you do
the course you've flown back and done
the other course and you're like and
you've just only gone all in and there
without much like heads up I was a bit
like caught me off guard saying okay
um you're like I'm gonna ring my mum and
check with her she didn't ring and say
do you think we should join the academy
it was more like I've just done it just
done it yeah
so yeah that was a bit of a shock but I
mean and I was just trying to convince
him to do it wasn't me that convincing
us about letting that information sort
of settle settle in and go yeah okay we
knew we needed that anyway coming back
from another country with all our life
eight years and moved to England you
need that Community if you just did it
on our own we just I know you you'd feel
a bit more vulnerable yeah it would be a
little bit more lonely I think quite
lonely as well we always thought
property would be a lonely thing you
know we would do it just us two and you
know I'd miss that kind of work
environment that you get being in
business and meeting people and but it
just totally opened my eyes up to how it
can be and how it should be really
because the best thing about the academy
has been the network of people just
having been able to ask yourself a
question or any of the great mentors or
you know just everyone else that's in it
as well doing the same things like they
just understand and they're in the same
boat and you know you've always got
someone to ask a question so it's been
amazing and how many since during the
academy how many properties have you
have you bought four that's a lot of
properties to buy isn't it I mean most
people wouldn't buy four properties in
their life it's quite huge really and
not only have you bought them but you're
going to be able to refinance them and
pull out the majority of your money and
just keep going again and again and
again yeah we've done that it's on two
of them yeah the other two on currently
ongoing so yeah so you'll kind of slowly
just refinancing them and then when one
project finishes you'll refinance it and
and snowball yeah we never knew that you
could do that you know refinance it and
pull majority yeah the commercial
valuations on sort of large-scale hmos
and yeah talk to me about some of the
deals and how you're finding them and
and what the valuations are and stuff
like that so you mentioned commercial
valuations for the hmrs talk to me about
that so at the moment we've got a six
and six going on yeah
yeah so that was purchased what for like
47 and a half it looks quite run down
that's cheap yeah yes it's a director
vendor and it's a beautiful Building 47
and a half Grand yeah yeah needs a lot
of work windows and roof
um but at the end when it's all said and
done that should be 95 more money out so
if you bought it for 47.5 what's the
refurb 100 16 113 I was 100 right 113
that's a big Reverb and you're going to
kick that out as like the six bed
ensuite yeah all ensuite yeah we're kind
of a higher end we want to offer a
really nice good quality accommodation
like nice homes for people but still
though that's only 150 Grand and then
you've got six ensuite bed HMO what do
you think the commercial valuation will
be on that we've been quoted anywhere
between 2 10 and 2 30. what's the
difference between a commercial
valuation and a bricks and mortar
valuation commercial based on the
revenue generated by the property right
over a course of there's a complicated
equation
that is multiple equations but basically
it's about what the rent is right the
higher the rent the higher the value
it's all based off yields and it is
quite common and it's a funny thing
because I do on the I don't know if you
remember on the bar refurbished
masterclass but I say because some
people say don't know oh you can just
find all the information on Google and
I'll say here's one for you here's a
property this is the rents workout on
Google or you can use chat gbt if you
want work out the value and no one can
yeah and you'll Google it and you'll
have a million different articles that
come up about commercial valuations and
it's a Minefield being able to
understand the formulas and have the as
you said the connections to the Brokers
and the lenders to actually tell you
what the values are going to be is is so
important that's what we've noticed as
well with this we've gone through like
two or three Brokers and some of them
don't have a clue about commercial and
some of them say you've got to wait this
long you need this kind of asts along
with the half the full package in order
to get the the valuation you want and
yeah a lot of Brokers say to you or
lawyers say do you know this can't be
done and yeah I know it can be done so I
know now other people that have done
this so it's just about finding the
right people and the biggest thing has
been finding a good Power Team and we
always knew we would have to do that
when we move back but yeah it's been so
much easier to find a good Power Team
from having this through the academy so
yeah recommend that guy or this person
you go it's so true because
sometimes people think just because an
accountant it can't be done therefore it
can't be done a lot of accountants
they're pretty broke you know and a lot
of professional people like that like
these um accountants and sisters they're
always looking for the problems and for
the reason why something can't be done
and it's important to be able to find
people like Brokers agents Specialists
surveyors that are finding Solutions and
finding out how it can be done how much
would that rent for them I mean
hartlepool's a pretty cheap area we
reckon about 500 a month per room but
they're high-end ensuite rooms yeah yeah
but we might even be able to get in on
the contractor Market which we know is
around a thousand pounds per month per
room yeah there is like a lot of
contractors in the area because it's a
big like area for the power there's a
few plants up there and a few other
industries that are working yes a lot of
Engineers are looking for rooms for
short terms days so when did you work
out that you could leave work because
now you're both full-time in property
right when and how did that happen well
because we were moving country because
we would decide to move back to England
give up our jobs anyway so we were just
all from the Stars like we're leaving
Dubai we're leaving our jobs and we're
going back to England to be full-time in
property so
yeah we just it's a case of having to
make it work and we've made a huge
sacrifice to be able to do that because
we've you know moved country we're
currently living at home with James's
parents so you know which which is crazy
because you're now officially property
millionaires but then it's it's funny
because it's like yeah we're probably
millionaires we've just bought four
houses but oh that money's going into
the business but actually you're not
driving fancy cars living the hard life
you're living with James's parents
living a very normal life but you're
building assets we had a conversation at
the accelerate coaching performance
program about how important it is to not
only have slow pound to build your
assets but also to have cash coming in
yeah and you had a challenge uh recently
to go and get a rent to rent for quick
cash flow what happened since you
decided to do that
yeah I I was just so fed up I was like
all our money is tied up in the
properties I need some fast pound it's
great we're building our portfolio and
our business and everything but we need
some money coming in I said to you do
you think we should try and get a rent
to sa you're like oh I'm so tied up with
this I was like well I'm gonna do it I'm
just gonna go out and do it and I went
on Gumtree that day and I found this
perfect little cottage 10 minutes down
the road in the countryside but it's
close to loads of I mean it is 10
minutes from the county town of Somerset
close to the coast and everything and I
went to visit at the landlord's like yep
come tomorrow first person to see it and
I was so nervous about broaching the
subject of like airbn being an owl and a
corporate let but he was totally open to
it he was like Yep this is great or what
I want is guaranteed rent if you can
offer me that then so how much did you
agree to pay him uh 9.75 a month and he
agreed have you have you like got the
contract signed yet I've got the
contractor send him today he's
agreed completely he's already taken it
off
how much will you rent it out for a
night then on average uh 125 I think
between 125 been peak times I'm going to
try and push to 165. so are you expected
to make how much profit you work in a
month I'm hoping to make a thousand yeah
and it might be less in in the winter
months it might be five or six hundred
but still it's that's the thing when you
own a property like when you do a br for
example you buy a house obviously if
it's a HMO a six-bit hm it might be
different but you can buy a house you
can do it up you can refinance it put
all your money out rent it for a grand
but then after you've paid your expenses
and your mortgage you're left with 200
quid a month profit so yes you're
building your assets but you need to be
also thinking about your monthly cash
flow as well and you've done that
through hmos how many of your full
properties that you've got how many of
them are hmos are three once they're all
completed and refinanced and rented how
much with your rent to rent how much
cash flow will you expect to make from
those uh we're hoping five to six
thousand a month yeah which is which is
which is our Financial Freedom we were
like we need 6 000 minimum to be able to
move out but then you'll have a whole
bunch of money back to reinvest and to
keep Recycling and growing and growing
and you're young as well it's not like
again like most people that are property
millionaires they'll be in their like
50s you know what I mean like it's very
very rare to be able to build a
portfolio like that in the way that you
have what would you say your tips would
be if you were advising somebody that
was new to the market that was wanting
to do what you've done become a property
millionaire and stop buying houses and
what will be the top tips that you would
recommend from your experience I mean my
top tip would be to network and educate
yourself yes definitely educated and you
surround yourself around the people that
know and don't try and reinvent the
wheel to sort of copy and paste yeah a
lot of people want to get into property
and they just jump in or they they read
all the books listen to all the podcasts
and then don't take action so my advice
would definitely currently be take
action but do the education first
because otherwise you'd be in stuck in a
situation like where we fit us for you
just buy one property or two properties
and then that's all your money gone and
it's tied up in those properties and
you're making a few hundred pound a
month it depends what your goal is but
if you want to be financially free from
property then you need to look at the
proper strategies and educate yourself
and then take the action and do it
because it's the best thing I think
we've ever done one of the things that
you you definitely couldn't ever say you
weren't is action takers you know the
two of you are both Massive Action
takers you know to move from Dubai quit
your jobs join the academy put in all
these offers buy these houses it's uh
it's commendable uh you're an asset to
the academy and uh I really appreciate
you coming around and sharing your story
on winners on a Wednesday thank you
thank you for having us amazing well
done respect congratulations well done
foreign
[Music]